hallo mein name ist luca herzlich
willkommen hier heute mal der liebe
zuschauer zu einer nicht lounge allen
zusammen mit juden bzw
gegen julia wir haben uns jeder zehn
sachen rausgesucht also das kann
beispielsweise ein mime sein das kann
auch ein witz sein das kann auch ein
video sein oder irgendwas als wäre jeder
medien rausgesucht um die andere person
zum lachen zu bringen ich starte hier
immer ganz leicht mit etwas wo ich
tatsächlich denke das ist das am
wenigsten lustig ist und zwar es ist das
hier das gibt's von milch wir machen es
übrigens nicht nur so dass man nicht
lachen sondern man das überhaupt keine
also sowas wer auch schon ein lachen
wenn er das ist weiter was ich für dich
rausgesucht habe ist auch noch kein
video sondern ein bild
es steht 2 1 für jule und wir kommen nun
zu einem ersten video ist ja okay das
nächste was ich für dich vorbereitet
habe es ebenfalls ein video
[Musik]
gut mein fehler
der raum genauso wie kommen wir nun zu
meinem nächsten video was ich für dich
vorbereitet habe man kennt glaube ich
dass ursprungs video aber ich bin
gespannt auf deine reaktion zeigt
übrigens fragt warum wir spaß dies über
sowas dummes lachen unserem osten
kindergarten sitzen geblieben
die wahrheit bei die als nächstes habe
ich für dich keine video sondern
tatsächlich wieder einmal die sache ist
wenn man es versteht dann ist es
vielleicht 40
also ich verstehe ist aber bei download
funktion ein gold typ puma war das übel
sitze jetzt hab ich endlich und ich bin
mir eigentlich sicher dass zu machen
wird
[Musik]
gar nicht kennen als nächstes habe ich
hier ein vielleicht sogar schon eher
trauriges video für dich du hast einfach
keine ruhe
endlich habe ich einen tick tock timo ja
ehrlich kennen das ding das ist bitter
für sie okay
als nächstes habe ich wieder ein fail
video für dich vorbereitet
beziehungsweise gar kein fell sondern
vielleicht wollte er es auch so was ist
mit dir so las ich über so was wie ich
habe ja ein video für dich von einer
katze
[Musik]
ja ich lache viel zu häufig über so
einen schwachsinn das letzte video von
mir für die schule ist wieder eine katze
ja das zeitige frühjahr waren
ich habe immer angegeben
[Musik]
jetzt so fand so traurig dass bei mir
eigentlich nur darüber gelacht wie ich
mit bart aussagen lästert er würde mir
das heute videos allerdings auch beenden
meine liebe zuschauer wenn es euch
gefallen hat das gerne mal einen
daumenbruch seit dachte mir es
vielleicht mal interessant wenn wir uns
gegenseitig versuchen so ein paar videos
rauszusuchen wo wir denken da könnte der
andere lachen ich habe gnadenlos
verloren was das ganze noch machen
sollen stadt gerne in die kommentare
[Musik]